bonsoir tout le monde sans déconner j'ai
l'impression d'être gad elmaleh
en moins rigide et encore pas longtemps
ya un mec qui est venu voir qu'il m'a
fait écoute franchement j'aurais jamais
cru qu'un mec comme toi ça pourrait être
marrant
bah ouais tu vois je sais quoi mais
comme moi c'est bien le 1 les cheveux
sales le déguisement quoi tous les trucs
à déguisements tous les trucs moches
bah ouais tu vois ouais non moi j'essaie
de rester cool entre de sacrifice de
vierges tu vois
imagine faire l'amour à que l'actrice de
films pornos être un peu comme un blanc
c'est un charlot dans le tunnel du mont
blanc
prends les autres à côté les yaourts
taillefine oui ça fait mincir et les
bains minova ça fait vieillir alors
ferme ta gueule c'est mieux
pour le plr